hey guys it's Inca you know sometimes
you have that like one thing from your
childhood that one like really special
food item that you just like keep on
thinking about you really miss even when
you're all grown up today I will be
recreating that taste of home for my
friend he is somebody who really really
liked boob a cake when he was a kid I
want to be able to recreate that taste
for him right here in the BuzzFeed
kitchen so let's bring in Steven hi
how's it going I know you're kind of
obsessed with eBay mm-hmm what is it for
people who don't know what it is oh god
I should have prepared what is uber uber
is purple yam it's popular in the
Philippines and used in a lot of
desserts I don't think of it as the yam
I think of it as the jam there's a
period in my childhood where I just
remember loving anything that was I
didn't grow up in the Philippines but it
was like that connection to who I was
family to our culture I didn't think
about it in that way but it was just
warm and it was purple and we didn't
have it all the time it was like special
occasions like on birthdays like
Christmas for us my momma or my cousin
would make like a big cake and it just
tasted so good my uncle usually grabs it
from this famous bakery ribbon
I liked it better than chocolate cake I
liked it better than vanilla cake even
though I'm a very vanilla person okay I
love vanilla everything but there was
the one where I was like when I was
looking at recipes Ruby cake
there was this ube hulk hawaii hawaii
hawaiian hilarya you say ha ha yeah the
stresses on the yeah and so Jaleo
hello yeah hello yeah hello yeah yeah
yeah hello hello yeah this was a key
component of that like ooh big cake
recipe do you have a family recipe for
that I texted my mom the recipe she
knows is from her mom my grandmother and
and it's like such a simple recipe I had
no idea I came ready I don't think about
these things it's like literally like
five ingredients let's start with this
let's make this happen and you can take
a photo and show it to your mom and say
that you finally made it after all these
years cool
literally never thought I would make it
but let's do it ube hell yeah
well hello this is after we boiled it so
beautiful I know you say your mom
doesn't make it I think she could and
after this I totally don't make her do
it
I thought you would say after this you
would make it for her yes that's what
I'm gonna do it's terrible I'm just
grading it so mushy and whoa weird it
looks like brains
according to grandma we only need two
cups of this so also I call my grandma
your Lola said five ingredients
evaporated milk butter tell me what this
is water lemon juice and sugar I thought
you knew your grandma's recipe you want
to do the honors yes can I do everything
should I be doing this like we do in
case you guys do in taste
he's like if I getting in a tasty mood
oh yes my family would be so proud this
year is the first year I've finally been
like okay it's time to grow up it's time
to start cooking but I literally have
yet to make a single Filipino dish and
this is my first in my life yeah
now it's uh gonna be on video forever it
took Engel em to get me to make Filipino
food I feel like in a lot of our
families we don't really have like
written recipes it's in the soul it's in
the gut yeah sure that's why the rest of
us don't know now we're gonna put in the
eBay look at that look at the colors
it's so purple love it I actually think
adding a little bit of condensed milk
makes it even creamier in Filipino
dessert there's a lot of good right can
i smoke yeah I remember being a kid is
like I'm not gonna do it
gonna eat it later you can't put my
finger in okay good nice look at that
I love hiring Lola said cook over low
heat until done she doesn't - say what
what the internet tells me is that it's
supposed to turn really sticky so now we
just wait wow you are a pro does this
look right yeah that's what I know
this is the ube you know you may add the
lemon juice wow you're just excited I'm
so for me all right all right yeah I
want one too cheers Cheers
that's good that's really good oh my god
that's so good Wow good job hey you did
it you told me what to do
oh my god it's milky it's creamy but you
get that movie flavor it's like not too
sweet
this is like what I remember when I was
like yeah my best memories of like
wanting this wasn't like from when it
was like four or five like warm fresh
baby my mom did I literally used to like
look for ube like because I remember it
tasting like this oh that's so I don't
even need to make cake anymore other
peoples I've tried - no this is like
what I remember it voicing like when I
was a kid before we go and use it this
is how we you know my dad it's not
really like in a jar now you can take
the tree home
yeah of course you can try you're gonna
have a lot to bring home I get to take
this home
yeah the best day
alright Steven likes it's time to close
it it's beautiful
yeah he just made that this is like
magical ha ha ha I like want this every
day earlier I took you asking me and it
took me a day or two to remember and
that's like holy crap when I was little
I used to want this so bad and I forgot
cuz nothing tastes like heaven
good no one's made my Lola's recipe so
high five all right reset and then cakes
yes cake let's do cake wait so we have
the dry ingredients here wet ingredients
and we have like a meringue base we're
gonna start by putting this in the stand
mixer egg whites sugar yeah literally
used to make meringue as a kid all the
time to logistics way really just to
make like pavlova oh good cuz it was
just eggs and sugar tell me you don't
cook we're gonna come here can we zoom
in on a Steven with this uh this baby
baby yeah you're a little eBay baby it's
so warm baby and she's gonna mix for a
while next things is to put this down
mixed up we're going to sift the dry
ingredients flour sugar salt baking
powder I'm baking yes you are here also
spilling everywhere well you didn't tell
me not to now we're just gonna sift it
all now we have the wet ingredients egg
booboo heylia
Wow you're seeing really also why is
there food color sheeting it's not just
so vibrant but when you bake it into a
cave it just becomes like a lighter
purple I know you want this to look like
the red ribbon bakery
ube cake keeping it I think is the
better idea a vegetable oil and milk
this is eBay extracts Oh
it smells like bubble tea and I put the
eggs in now ooh this is a fun Wow we
need to do this all the time do it at
your apartment will do more parties look
at that cool it's like magic why is it
food coloring so thick this is movie
extracts oh it's purple I handed you you
ready for this one your favorite oh no
it's stuck oh I don't know what I'm
doing oh I got it I got it you got it I
got this ready I'm just mixing it oh my
god I'm so nervous
cool just mix it until it's combined and
then we're good
Wow I need to bake more often maybe I'll
make you a cake for Christmas
oh the ideas I told you life-changing so
we're done with the whisk and meringue
is almost done Boop this be so stiff
nice we're just gonna fold it in we
don't want to mix it too much because if
we do then all the air will go out
[Music]
all right can I try the cake better are
you okay with raw eggs yeah kids don't
do this ask your parents before you do
it
I can taste the meringue and the batter
you can't oh my god cake batters the
best my god
I do a little tap tap see how instantly
helps the boy you know the Tri poll that
just gave me that oh it just got
goosebumps okay okay not like this
gentleman so far so good
so the cakes are out of the oven I'm
just letting it cool in the fridge
meanwhile we're gonna work on the cream
cheese frosting oh I love cream cheese
frosting I feel like everything this
whole day has been my favorite look at
how thick and fluffy it is
oh wow I've never held of a cake with my
hands before this is interesting he has
so many weird AFER's we're gonna
actually cut it remember the red ribbon
cake it has like the crumbles on top
fourth layer we're gonna crumble that
one up you're so fancy I'm not fancy I'm
just falling follow your dreams
the picture you painted for me oh it's
it's very moist had no idea that that's
what you do you ready
you got it
Oh Agis have a same reaction to what hey
I'm just gonna tear it up do it it's
toss it in its social in here now that
it's in all hope is not lost it I knew
it just go dude
[Music]
I'm gonna take it out take time mm I'm
gonna do a little dab dab here dab
bottom layer big piece glue it on there
put some of this cream cheese frosting
on top of it getting hungry all over
again and I'm so full what did you say
you were on a food coma I know but I'm
getting hungry for dessert so it is now
frosted and they just like it's just
yeah I'm not gonna sell me this we're
just gonna do don't move a it okay not
like that you said I could
you can do whatever you want this shirt
do a little pep pad green now it's
really purple rain don't forget the
sides you want to press it on there
[Music]
this it's an ube glaze a lot of powdered
sugar and water and butter to give it
that nice shine through the cream first
here we go
Wow beautiful now do we get to eat your
mom hi hi look mom we made a movie cake
and look we made a bet how they up from
scratch oh my god you know how to make
it I do now I'll bring this home and
then we can make some at home for
Christmas
Oh mother you're adorable
is it time time meeting time oh wow that
is kind of perfect oh my god and with
that icing hmm everything I remember
from being good Wow my life is forever
change thanks Inga making your dreams
come true
I love this I'm gonna take my jam I'm
gonna take my cake and I will see you
later
let us know what chaga recipe that you
really liked down below in the comments
and see you next time
you
[Music]